dans les rues de Laigneville l'affaire
fait beaucoup rire ils font trop de
bruit dans leurs ébats sexuels
et on a porté plainte pour ça c'est dans
un de ces immeubles que plusieurs
habitants se sont pleins débats amoureux
devenus trop bruyants et trop fréquent
je comprends que ça puisse déranger les
voisins faudrait qu'ils essayent
peut-être de faire un effort retrouver
une solution je sais pas isolé la
chambre le maire de la commune quant à
lui c'est saisi du dossier les policiers
municipaux ont rencontré le couple en
question et il espère que la
médiatisation de cette affaire calmera
leurs ardeurs
est-ce que tu veux dire je suis
scandalisé par l'action du maire par les
plaints
qui hurle c'est pour ça
bravo
non mais ça va arrête de te prendre la
tête pour tout Jean-Mi le problème c'est
pas les nuisances c'est que ça crée des
des problèmes dans les autres couples où
les femmes reprochent au mari genre elle
a de la chance
gueule parce que ça des
frustrations
[Rires]
qui existe sur terre et on peut même
plus le faire en de manière libérée
c'est vous qui faisait du bruit
c'était mon grand-père
[Rires]
20 fois si ça réveille les enfants c'est
l'énorme
très bien mais voilà et à ce moment-là
il faut être un peu quand même dans la
médiation il faut quand même la
médiation
sauf que c'est tu ne peux pas contrôler
tu peux baisser la musique là quand tu
écoutes
je pouvais pas lui dire
moins fort mais c'est incontrôlable
d'appartements à Los Angeles à un moment
où il y avait des
il y avait un couple de voisins il
faisait exprès d'ouvrir les fenêtres
voilà c'était de l'exhibitionnisme et
une fois ça fait marrer deux fois trois
fois et au bout d'un moment on en peut
plus ça devient bien sûr
on a le coupable
moi dans un hôtel
de ville et il y avait une chambre comme
ça où le mec il en a assez excité comme
des oufs et on sait tous retrouver sur
le sous le palier sur le palier parce
que personne n'arrive à dormir et on a
porté plainte pour que les mecs
et sachez que la police est arrivée
imaginez que ça se reproduise comme ça
tous les soirs
je vais regarder
quand même pour savoir qui c'était